now a few weeks out from Thanksgiving a  lot of places are looking to do some  seasonal hiring yeah and that includes  Opportunity Village the nonprofit as you  know here in the valley cares for those  with disabilities and employs them as  well and is looking to hire 60 direct  support professionals  Opportunity Village has a number of  positions that are open and available  and today we're focusing on our direct  support professionals there's a  lifeblood of what we do in supporting  people with intellectual and  developmental disabilities  OV does such great work here in the  valley you can find a link to apply at  the Opportunity Village website for a  full list of companies and other  non-profits that are hiring here in the  valley head to 8newsnow.com click on the  job board tab we have a list with links  for you to apply